on this episode I talk about being an
actor being a mom and being a recent
graduate you ask questions and I answer
them this is the askgaryvee show
hello everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 70 of
the askgaryvee show
lovely Monday morning goddamn I see rain
snow mix in New York has completely
flipped my entire schedule it's insane
that the the the lack of grit in New
York City area right now is pissing me
off the fact that I've had seven
different meetings canceled today is
disturbing at best and if you're
watching the show and you can't tell
them me yes I'm calling you out
you're soft all right excited about the
show last episode was super great trying
to get one in on Friday but then we got
crunched at the last second almost got a
five were in last week which would have
been insane wanna want to thank all the
vaynernation listening to the podcast
and watching the show enjoying it we've
hit a milestone episode number 70 a
little fun fact I don't know if you know
this but ninety nine point six percent
of all shows on YouTube never make it to
their 70th episode I made up that fact
let's put up the made-up fun fact logo
there and let's go into this show you
like that house ever let's go Neil asks
looking for a marketing job right out of
college is tough
especially finding one that's not
sketchy how do you find a job that's the
right fit the answer who who asked the
question again Neil it's sounds like by
the way you're asking the question I'm
glad we're getting to attack this that
you're looking at what is dean this
internet marketing right when you say
that all marketing jobs are coming at a
school I think what you're falling into
is kind of those ebook kind of landing
page you know the bad version of all
these great growth hackers out there the
bad version of that right lowest common
denominator play an arbitrage internet
marketing buy my ebook in the back room
and a discs MLM it sounds like you're
going down a funnel and and what you
deem is marketing is scummy and I
understand a lot of that gets into dark
marketing but nineteen eight percent of
the marketing jobs in the world are like
working at Vayner meat this is a
marketing like you know so first of all
I recommend recalibrating how your
positioning marketing and make sure that
you're not going down the rabbit
of internet marketing and I keep quoting
it like this first I love air quotes and
we all know that but second there is
that term for you know just copywriting
make landing pages of like red and
yellow and buy this and whether you're
selling supplements or an e-book or
information play that game out that's
not the world of marketing that I
believe in or think about and so I would
tell you that there are eight billion
agencies marketing digital social
agencies out there and I would
immediately go get an internship if you
can't get a job and prove that you've
got the chops right I mean it's
unbelievable how high of a percentage of
the interns that we get here at
vaynermedia we offer a job to one we're
growing fast so that makes sense but
they've come in and they've hustled and
so the lack of internship or internship
out of college if the market is bad
blows me away it seems like the markets
getting better jobs are being created
more at this scale than say 24 to 36
months ago but the famous d-roc story or
any other story like the ability for you
to go and work for somebody pro bono to
get a resume I mean look to me if you're
struggling to get a job for two three
four or five months out of school why in
the world you wouldn't take a half of
your day each day to then work somewhere
for free or intern or whatever whatever
whatever it is to a pick up skills B
network C learn your craft and action
and watch it D create the leverage and
almost guilt your employer into hiring
you or making them tell somebody else to
hire you you know better than sitting
around and moping about why it's not
working out unless you're out there
literally in job interviews or huh or or
sending resumes I mean you've got
eighteen hours in a day to execute this
and so you know to me you could be doing
that from 7:00 p.m. till 2:00 in the
morning and then from 9:00 to 7:00 you
can go do it go work at a probe go go
work at a pro bono place or a museum or
put your skills into action if you're a
marketer Dana asks how would you advise
a young woman to brand herself on
YouTube if she's worried about privacy
and security for her family Dana that's
a tough question for me to answer
because I'm acutely aware that a lot of
practices that I do I would struggle to
execute if I was a woman
and definitely like the thing that I
spent a lot of time on this lately
serendipitously I've been in a couple of
meetings where couple friends that are
what I would call very attractive girls
and that becomes an in you know call it
whatever you want to call it that
becomes a whole nother variable and so
you know women have it different I mean
that you know I'm thrilled for people
leave comments and I know they will and
say no yes women have a different
african-americans have a different like
Latinos have a different like context
out there is different white males have
certain advantages and putting yourself
out there as a woman leads to dudes
being dudes and when I mean that is
dudes or jerk-offs and they're scum
buckets and just it's just how we roll
like like don't be mad at us like we've
given we were given chemicals that made
us want to be hunters and we just don't
know how to handle that ninety-four
percent of the time I'm in the six
percent and so what I would say is like
carefully I mean I'm petrified to give
an answer here because if one deems into
you know an uncomfortable situation for
you but I think look I think that
there's different levels I mean the fact
here's a good example it is very hard to
find pictures of my kids on the Internet
right and your question actually has
your child in the picture I'm not
calling you out for that I'm saying
clearly you have some comfort level of
putting yourself out there this is not
an answer for me or for anybody else is
an answer for yourself but what I would
tell you is to be careful but to
recognize that people are good the
number one underrated brand in the world
is human beings the mainstream media
spends all of its time telling us about
the terrible point oh one percent of us
as humans but the truth is it is
stunning in the world that we live in
now where everybody's putting out their
information where they are how they roll
who the relatives are how empty their
home is remember when Foursquare came
out every was like oh everybody's gonna
rob you
because let's put that article I'm gonna
find it it's like put it up here like
this was an article that was literally
written Google right now like burglar
Foursquare robbing your house like
everyone's like oh you can't check in
two places because people don't know
you're not home and they're gonna rob
you
Ludacris you found it already yeah
please rob me it doesn't happen because
99.999% of us who are watching the show
living in this world are good people so
look I'm not going
you advise on this because I care way
too much about the health and well-being
of your family and I care way less than
you do so you need to roll your way but
I will say this you know people are good
and like it's stunning
how many more bad things can happen to
you by percentage then the stalker
that's going to come to your house and
hurt you like it is far riskier to drive
a car than 99% of the things that people
talk about around social media so you
know that's just my context point but I
will not give you an answer because when
it comes to family everybody has to make
their own decisions
Jonny asks any tips on giving a great
right hook sweep the leg Johnny
sweep the leg and that's literally how I
think about this I mean the fact of the
matter is you got to go in for the kill
just much like Karate Kid where that
quotes from they his teammates like
sweep the leg Johnny like go in for it
how do you throw a right hook honesty
you know what a good Superbowl
commercial is in my opinion hey I'm Gary
Vaynerchuk I'm the CEO of Toyota I want
you to buy cars from us let us know how
we can make that happen that's a good
Superbowl commercial because forget the
pony and the eagle and the cute dog and
everything else you want to sell cars
and I think that Americans you know what
let's do a test case right now
what's jab jab jab right hooks Amazon
ranking right now I'm gonna show you
Johnny how to sweep the leg what see it
was on rank right now on Jeff do you
know how to find it I know if I don't
real fast since I look at it all the
time you probably do in India I mean all
the time when I'm selling I haven't
looked at this in months and months and
months 2847 that's the rank ready
everybody who's watching this show it
would mean the world to me to be able to
the land the right hook I'm right
throwing right now a lot of you have the
book already so it's hard for me to ask
for how much is it on Amazon right now
17:43 AM and Kindle 49 I am asking every
single person who's watching this show
right now to buy one one one Jab Jab Jab
right hook it would mean a lot to me
I would prove my point to Johnny I would
equally benefit from that because I make
a dollar 3 the dollar - 3 cents or three
dollars per book or whatever it is this
point I'm done promoting jabs
but it's the most tangible thing that we
can all watch together I'd like you to
buy more if you were ever thinking about
buying it for your staff you can send
one for your Kindle anybody who's
watching and if you've watched more than
25 shows of the askgaryvee show and you
don't own a copy of Jab Jab Jab right
hook you need to that is absolutely a
must and so that is my right hook and
honestly Johnny that is and obviously I
don't know how you can link up obviously
can't go to Amazon but like link it in
the comments and that's all right hook
you just honestly ask you you try to
create some guilt around it like you've
watched 30 shows can't you give me 15
bucks you try different angles you just
go straight for it you don't hedge you
ask for the sale of Jab Jab Jab right
hook goby asks how do you leverage
social media when you're an
up-and-coming actor you know Gopi I
think one of the things that you need to
be thinking about is your target
audience so yes put out content I love
the stuff that you're putting out I love
the picture in a public store and I've
been seeing the love from you on
Instagram so I appreciate it brother
you know I think that um I think that
one of the things I would do is map the
people that can get you roles in your
country so literally you probably know
the names of the casting directors or
the networks that will book you like
literally down to the name like Simon
Thompson is did I nail it where he's
from
I admit how good I am India tell me
let's talk about this
I'm busy guy right I'm a busy guy right
and the fact that you could bring him up
right out and say that and then I could
tell you which country you're impressed
a minute cuz you're cool sorry that was
just for me
India is just a pure character and I
just always loved to show her like how
into it I really am that's good stuff
right thank you
it's enough to you right come on you're
like weird
look I think there's the fifty to eighty
people that you know the names of in
Norway that book you know the television
shows or the commercials or whatever
you're trying to nail and so I would go
after them directly meaning I would try
to put content in front of them on
Facebook if you can buy ads around the
places they work I would literally reply
all 80 of them if they're on Twitter
let's call four of them are on there so
you could say hey but don't be stalkers
like hey book me be like you know look
for things they're talking
about and reply to that but I in your
situation in many situations in a b2b
world for a lot of people that are
watching this find out who you're
looking for and go directly at them by
either running ads against them right so
like you'd their description where they
live their age group you can find them
on Facebook dark posts go to look at
LinkedIn and see who you're connected to
with them and maybe put out content to
that person and maybe I mean look if you
have a buddy who's connected to the
person that you need to get to all right
India's connected to the Iraq we're
tight but I'm not tight with d-roc and
he's a casting person on channel two in
Norway like it's okay to say India I'm
gonna put out a video that's really
funny if you can retweet it that would
be awesome because I know that the Iraq
follows you and maybe he'll see it
that's an indirect direct way tangible
black and white piece of advice that may
lead to the serendipity I can go
directly to the Iraq or the other thing
is Dirac is on Twitter and he tweets
about the the presidential election in
Norway or the kangaroo you know and I
jump in and like get involved there's a
lot of ways to make yourself aware it's
all attack right it's like how you gonna
roll up on that person if you want a
relationship with them whether you're
hitting on a girl or hitting on a guy by
the way did you guys see the Julian
Edelman snapchat tinder controversy Oh
anyway let's just maybe you think of it
anyway I've got to show you after we're
done taping anyway or you're trying to
you know there was a business meeting I
was in the other day where I wanted to
get to the person like what's my way in
that's not too forceful you know it's
the Mick that's you know it's almost
this imaginary blend of what's the blend
between a jab and a right hook a jabber
rock you know like there's something
there and so it's tak it's always tacked
and so but I would say it starts with
you've got 80 I'm gonna assume there's
thirty five to a hundred people that you
know you need to get to get to them
before we go away I know that's gonna be
cool because please understand
vaynernation
in 2015 he can get to those thirty-five
200 people you couldn't before
1989 you call like you call like CBS and
you like can I speak now they like they
like they will transfer an assistant
like
wouldn't get to people that's what the
internet and what the maturity of the
Internet the current state of the
internet the word we use to call the
Internet what it is right now social
media is you can and I don't mean
LinkedIn can I just been there's a lot
of you know been jamming on LinkedIn I
don't mean like hit them up and be like
I mean social like talking to the
president of CBS on Twitter about the
Super Bowl which leads to awareness I
mean making a piece of content that gets
shared by the friends so that the
president season of CBS you know that
you can get to people now that's huge
so many of you gotten to me you couldn't
have gotten to me in 1989 that would
have been a secretary and Ruth would
have been like no ruses you ask
questions and I answer them
this is
Ishmael a great question not really
actually actually think it's a very
below average question I wouldn't answer
it unless I thought your talent was so
awesome
I basically am answering this question
strictly for two reasons one you've been
a hardcore part of my community for the
last nine ten twelve months at least and
- that was really rad I love that video
and I'm hoping that people were watching
this show might hit you up and have you
do something for 500 bucks for them I
think we should maybe even use him for
something anyway nonetheless yeah I
don't know question of the day what is
your snapchat username because I want to
use the screen to like follow some of
you here's mine good before I close with
my you keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them
I just want to say a couple of things I
am spending enormous amount of time on
Instagram snapchat LinkedIn Pinterest
Facebook Twitter my friends we are
living through I promise you I'm gonna
look back at this clip in 35 years would
be like we are living through such an
interesting time of communication and
marketing one that we've not seen in a
very I actually think the maturity of
the internet social graph right now the
most similar thing was really kind of
like you know the beginning that this is
the most I have felt disruption and
opportunity since the Oh 607 Facebook
and Twitter growth from let's say the
myspace Friendster beginning please
please understand that the next 24
months of Hustle is probably a little
bit more valuable than normal hustle
because the stakes are high the
opportunities are high there's a lot of
disruption people are just settling into
a Facebook and Twitter world and the
world is moving on them take advantage
you keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them the last episode I don't
care I like wearing the same clothes
certainly I like this sweater are you
sure it wasn't the other blue one but I
bought another blue one that's super
close show me show me I'll freakin wear
the same I'm gonna wear the same sweater
all week and your face d-roc what do you
think about that
cuz I've two that are super close
anytime man episode 6 and I wore maroon
sweater
hey you guys are you guys are lost
yeah you guys are a bunch of lost kid
well you said oh I think you've been
putting the blame on India yeah nor
should you dear Rach all right